GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SIX IS HEREBY COLD
WATER PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT
AUDIO VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IS BEING
MADE AND SALAS WE TELEVISE
A MAN SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
QUIRK SILVA FOLKS HERE
RIVAS WICKS HERE
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
WELL -- YEAH WE'RE WAITING
WE'LL ON THIS VERY RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE CONSIDERATION
OF I AM NOT LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEE OUR ONE THREE
HEALTH OKAY -- THEN WE WILL
REMOVE ITEM FOR A SURE ONE
THIRTY WEBER FROM THINK WE'LL
JUST TAKE THAT CENTER LINE IS
OUR MOTION REMAINDER THE CONSENT
AGENDA SECOND A MOVE ON THIS
WORK SECOND BY MISTER MATHIS
-- ANSWER TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HI THE LADY I
CUNNINGHAM FOR RIO RIO AYE FLORA
OR I GRAYSON BY RACE AND I
KAMLAGER-DOVE KAMLAGER-DOVE
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE AYE
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA I RAMOS
ALMOST I RIVAS RIVAS I WEBSITE
LOOKS FIVE ENGINE THAT MOTION
PASSES -- IS OUR MOTION ON
ITEM NUMBER FOUR ZERO THIRTY
MOTION MOVED RUMORS FROM
SORT OF OUR MYSTERY LISTS
-- MINUTES SECTOR THIS CALL
COOLEY HI I CUNNINGHAM
FOR RIO RIO AYE FLORA
VOTING GRAYSON BY RACE AND I
KAMLAGER-DOVE FACT KAMLAGER-DOVE
I AM MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS MATHIS NOT
VOTING QUIRK SILVA FIRST
OF ALL I RAMOS ROSS I RIVAS
RIVAS AYE WORKS I WICKS I
MOTIONS PASS AND -- THIS RULES
PROCEDURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YEAH